Hello, good morning. Good
afternoon and welcome. Welcome.
If you're dialing in from
somewhere across the world,
very excited to have our guests here
today and to talk about one of the areas
were completely different
disciplines are coming together, uh,
to make leaps in science
and in creativity. So, um,
I'm going to introduce our guests and
they're gonna share a little bit about
some of the stuff we've
been doing together and then
we're going to try and have
a conversation hopefully involving,
uh,
those of you in the room as
well about what's been going
on. Um, I'm Matt Britain.
If you don't know me, look off to Google
business and operations in Europe,
Middle East and Africa and wearing a
suit. A, that's part of what I have to do.
Apologies. Um, I first met, uh,
the team at the Natural History Museum
in my day job about eight years ago, uh,
when I was running our UK business and
they were talking about what can we do
with our collection in the digital world.
There's probably something there now.
It's taken them and us a bit of
time to get our stuff together. Uh,
but over a 10 month period,
the team led by the cultural
institutes and uh, say, uh,
his who his hair and armpit and team
work with about a hundred different teams
to people from teams across Google to
help to digitize a whole bunch of natural
history, uh, not just from
the natural history museum,
but from 60 different
museums. Uh, 300,000 photos,
videos and documents from those museums
as part of Google Arts and culture.
And we're going to have a little bit
of a look at some of that later in the
natural history museum was a primary
partner and our guests today, uh,
Eno ins who's here, uh, is, uh, leading
the natural history museums work,
um, uh, joined them from
Imperial College. Uh,
he's previously been
institute of Zoology in uh,
in Queensland final of
Queensland in Australia, the
Zoological Society of London.
He's a research fellow there. Uh,
he sits on the natural environment.
Research Council is post genomics and
protein. I don't even know where that is.
Proteomics. We'll find out
about that steering committee.
A vice president of the council, the
British trust for ornithology atrocity,
the national biodiversity,
a network,
and you oversee the work of 300
different scientists and a huge,
a collection of 70 million
different specimens.
And we might talk a bit about that as
well as write your CV so long that I won't
go through it. You don't mind. Um,
there are lots of other things I
don't understand on it as well.
And then Vince who's here,
uh,
started as an evolutionary biologist
and is really leading the application of
digital technologies to the study and
taxonomy of biodiversity and he's head of
informatics at the Natural History Museum.
That's probably not a role that was around
when it was founded back in the day.
So we might talk about that as well.
But first can I invite Ian to just share
a little bit about the work that you've
been doing and then we'll have a chat.
Sure. So I don't want this
to turn into a lecture.
I was in universities for 20 years, so I
was warning Matt. I am prone to that. Um,
but hopefully you've all, you all
know about the natural history museum.
One of the pleasures of working here,
you show this sort of image,
you say where you're from.
It's got a big brand globally,
about 5 million people come here,
here physically about the same number
of visitor exhibitions around the world
and about double that visitors digitally
at the moment. So it's got a big brand.
Now this place was founded.
Why?
It's based on a collection from
that was started in the 16 hundreds.
It started as the British Museum.
So it was very much a product
of the age of reason. Um,
people coming out of a period when the
mythology and religion with the dominant
and ways of understanding the world,
these sorts of institutions were
really created to start to um,
talk about the world
rationally and explain it.
Cause one of the key parts of that
was to find objects around the world,
bring them to a big hub,
actually show them to sue people.
So we've got a few slides here we
can dip in and out of these arm,
go through a few of them.
This is what if you think about the big
hall at the Front of the Natural History
Museum, this is what's on the
ceiling is absolutely beautiful.
This actually tells a quite an
important point about our founding.
This is a whole series of plants which
are of industrial or medical importance.
So these sorts of institutions
were founded partly out
of raw curiosity for the
natural world. And particularly with
the history of the natural world.
They were all there were always intended
also to be a tool for exploration in
terms of innovation as well. So
things like cocoa plants, coffee,
potatoes and so on. They all came
through these sorts of institutions.
The other thing,
of course,
these institutions contain some
unbelievably cool objects that have really
changed the way that individuals have,
have,
have affected how we all
think about the world here.
So on the left here and once, some
of my favorite specimens, those, uh,
those aren't just what we always joke
there was that aren't just any Darwin's
finches.
There was a Darwin's Darwin's finches.
So these are the sorts of objects that
really started making us think about, um,
evolution and natural selection.
That Brown object at the top,
that is the first bit of dinosaur that
somebody dug up and figured out what it
was. There was a really nice story about,
they realize, my goodness, it's a lizard,
but it's the lizard that's
about 30 meters long.
So that's the first dinosaur bottom there.
That's the first non human human
that we dug up from Gibraltar.
When people started figuring out there
were other humans around at some stage.
And if you think about what that meant
back in that time, we were the only human,
the world that only been around a few
thousand years of power to suddenly say
unambiguously and to show there were
other humans around. That was a rev,
intellectually revolutionary
moment. Um, I know over here,
Vince will probably talk about
this. This is, um, this is,
we have the thing that it
says, one of them got up, um,
the Galapagos mockingbirds actually it's
these specimens rather than the finches
that Darwin actually started
thinking about evolution.
He actually collected these things.
And the next day in his notebook when
he wasn't being sick, I'm in the Beagle,
he started to write a little what we
would now call trees of life and say,
I think things change.
So when you put these in front of people,
as we do both physically and
now through the institute,
you can always captivate people first of
all about the object and then about the
people.
But then it's the big idea.
And of course what we're interested in
at the moment is it's no longer necessary
to bring people to that
institution in South Kensington.
We want this to be available
to anybody anytime, anywhere.
And that's all about digital
and genomic technologies.
You want me to just
keep going for a minute?
I or maybe a couple of these here
are some of the sorts of specimens.
Are there sort of data that we work with?
Huge collections of insects, 27 million,
um, pin insects. It's Pr.
I always check with Vince.
It's probably the most analog thing
that I know. Who in the world,
if you want to get the, these, these, um,
insects have been incredibly
important in demonstrating, um,
climate change.
If you want to know what some one of
those labels and the data behind that you
have to go to that object will lift up
the specimen and write it out yourself.
It's an amazingly analog system.
It's been like that for
let's say 250 years.
Our job is to destroy that intellectual
model and to make that information
freely available. I could see, you know,
you, you've barcoded them now. Yeah.
So this is, we've, we've um, had
a project where we've bark out,
we've now digitized, um, the
UK lepidoptera collections,
that's butterflies and moths, two words.
That's about 800,000 specimens. Um,
it was a demonstration project to say,
to show that this can be done and these
are the sorts of pipelines that you need
to set up, um, to do it. So yes,
that database is on the best
place to get to that database,
to that data at the moment would be
through the Google Cultural Institute.
300,000 of them are on
there. So we've started, um,
digitizing some of our collections.
This also shows, so for example,
with the recent Ebola outbreaks,
one of the first things you need to figure
out for something like Ebola is where
did it come from?
Almost everything that will really
kill humans on a large scale is leaping
across the humans from something
else, relatively recently, Ebola,
as an example of that. So when you try
and figure out where that comes from, you,
you realize it's from the fruit
bats that live in that area.
And you go back into
the collection and say,
how long is a bowl of
being in these fruit bats?
You can use genetic techniques to extract
that. So sometimes it's unexpected.
It's not always systematic digitization,
sometimes other things like that.
Um, uh, drew might, um,
drew pervs is hair from the mindset and
Andrew probably recognizes this year,
a collaborator collaborator
in this project, aren't you?
This is a big project
called them predicts.
This is trying to mobilize the sort of
data we've just been looking at to first
of all, map biodiversity in the
world. Now then figure out, um,
what our impact,
what humanities impact has been on that
by diversity and then predict the future.
So that's something that we're really
interested in because we want to give
people hope about the future as well as
making them realize that there's some
big decisions to be made and that sort
of analysis that these guys have been
doing,
um,
demonstrate that the decisions we in right
now could I have a really big impact,
not just over the next hundred years,
for the next 50 years,
but they are very data intensive compared
to the sorts of studies that people
used to do before on here. Um,
we calculated the other day,
there's the prevalence of about 65
million individual animals labeled on this
map.
So that's,
and that's the sort of data that you
need in the natural history collections
around the world.
There's probably between about one and
a half and 3 billion data points just
from the specimens.
That's not even going into the literature.
Okay. I'll probably stop on this slide.
This is where the challenges start.
So what we can do at the moment,
we feel that we know roughly what we
want to do and we have some pipelines set
up for doing that, be they physical or
infomatic. It's really scaling that up.
So at the moment we're doing a
few hundred thousand specimens.
I think on the Google Cultural Institute
today, there's about 300,000 specimens.
That's a lot compared to what
museums have done before,
but if we're trying to get into
the millions and the high millions,
you need to really scale that. Then
that really becomes an informatic issue.
This is a great example of this.
This is about as bad as the collections
get in terms of hard to change anything
from analog into digital.
Here's a typical curator.
This is Max Barclay in charge of our
beetle collection. Fascinating stories,
sort of his collection
laid out in front of him.
If you actually go and look
at one of those objects,
they're quite often like that.
So you can see in this case,
a fly at the top there and then he can
see that set of labels underneath it.
That's the metadata in many cases were
much more interested in that data than we
are to be honest in the fly.
We'd like a leg off the flight,
get the genome from it,
then we want the data.
Maybe you can see at the moment what we
do is we tend to one, pick those labels,
photograph them and then start
extracting information off that.
That's okay for a few tens of thousands,
for a few millions, you need to,
you need to break that.
Similarly,
you can see the way that the
different labels or um, uh,
typed out or written there. You can see
that, um, how are you going to do that?
You're really going to
transcribe that by hand.
So at the moment we sometimes use a
curator to an expert if you like to
transcribe that.
But typically we want to apply OCR first.
We want to cut that image
up, put it back together. Um,
use OCR to figure out what
sort of like a labels. Um,
so we've got some image recognition
software to look at what's a return label
and what's a handwritten label.
Then we want to use OCR on
the written or typed labels.
Then we started to go down
into their handwritten labels.
We crowdsource some of that
really fun crowd sourcing,
but at the moment we can digitize
things about 10 times as fast as we can
crowdsource them.
So we need to only be serving things
to real humans that need a real human's
mind.
We need to do everything we can without
that human mind before that last result
if you're like,
so that fascinating.
I think all of us can
understand the parallels between
the sort of tagging taxonomy,
a structured sets and the
ingestion of large amounts of data.
And we'll talk a bit
more about some of that.
Maybe let's just end by looking at one
of the ways in which the teams work with
you to try to make this
stuff more accessible. Uh,
I think we've got a little
video of the Romaleos. Saurus
can we,
can we go and have a quick look at that?
Cause I think the other part of what
we're trying to do is obviously increased
people's interest in accessibility to
this. So let's have a look at this.
Many of you have seen some of this,
but to have a look if you haven't at
the arts and Culture App and these
connections that are
really a sensation on,
and it's a sense that we're just
starting the journey of what's possible.
I would still ask you events,
uh,
about your personal journey because as
an evolutionary biologist to become the
head of the informatics division,
how did that start? Yeah,
that's a bit of a loose
about the journeys. I mean,
started perhaps like I guess
like many phd students in, in,
in the UK with an interest in the
natural world. And I wanted to find the,
an interesting project to work on. And
the group that I chose to work on, um,
was a rather obscure in group
called parasitic lights.
So we're familiar with them as the
parasites that live in our, uh,
sometimes live in our school, children's
hair, and a very difficult to get rid of.
But they're really fascinating group
because they've coevolve with the hosts
over millions and millions of years.
And when I started to work on them,
there was very little known about them.
So I started a database. I started, um,
very crude and rudimentary digital
techniques to try and build that,
that put that data together.
It was also at a time when the web was
almost just being born is about 2000.
So about 1997 to 2000. I did my phd. And,
um,
the web was just being explored as a
scientific tool and increasingly we needed
to build databases to share that
information, to make it accessible,
to make it curator bubble.
Yeah.
All right.
So this is actually at the time when the
web was being used in the way that it
was designed by, you know, affected
by Tim in terms of research.
Exactly. And, um, I started to,
because there were no easy to
use tools that are out there,
I really have to build
those systems myself.
So very simple system sharing
information about specimens, images,
molecular data,
and trying to do that in a way that
would bring in many of my colleagues.
Because, as you can imagine, there aren't
many Laos authorities around the, uh,
in the UK.
They tend to be very widely scattered.
I needed to communicate with them and
I needed to be able to bring their
expertise to this database. And then
over time, of course I realize that the,
the rather parochial little problem
that I had in trying to understand the
evolution of this group was a PA in
parallel really to everybody, other,
all the other authorities working
on other taxonomic groups.
And so we started instead of building
systems just to study parasitic lice,
we started to build platforms,
platforms that would work
for other taxonomic groups.
And that was when I started to get
very seriously interested in digital.
And was there a moment where you could
see the potential of this technology?
I mean obviously you started because you
were just doing your own cataloging and
then you start to connect with others.
Was there a moment where you
started to go, oh, I can see
how big this? I think, um,
probably that moment was when
I started to collaborate on a,
a global project called the tree of life
to actually share that information on
what was at the time.
It still exists actually a pretty
rudimentary website where we are trying to
share data about the evolutionary
history of taxonomic groups. And a,
an uh,
an evolutionary biologist in the u s had
built this platform that was critical
to building those evolutionary crease
and allowed us to share that data.
And then I started to
collaborate on that project.
That was probably the epiphany moment
when I started to realize there's really
something in this for many other taxa
in terms of how we do this at a global
level.
But it all started with light.
It all started with this very curious
group of about 5,000 species of parasites
on about 5,000 species of mammal,
about 10,000 species of bird and about
12,000 associations between those and as,
as a student basically trying
to manage all of that data,
trying to extract that from the scientific
literature, that's an enormous task.
You break it up into small enough chunks
and you distribute the problem and
actually it becomes a tractable problem.
Fantastic.
And they'll tell us a bit more about
where you are today and the focus that you
have today with a digital portal,
with all the specimens that you're in,
the process of digitizing.
So I think there's two big challenges now.
So I lead the informatics group within
the museum and I think we have two big
challenges, one of which and alluded to
and it's beautifully illustrated there,
just the sheer scale of the collection,
the enormity of this physical
collection and trying to digitize that,
that insect that you see,
that pinned insect,
that fly there is a good
example of digitizing that
through traditional methods.
Takes about two minutes and 20 seconds
to take all of those labels off,
to take a photograph to get
a rudimentary transcription.
And what we really want to do is
speed that process up. So robotics,
I can potentially help using, um, uh,
tools are able to allow us to digitally
reconstruct the label without physically
having to take them off. Unfortunately,
some of those labels are folded. So alas,
we can't,
yeah,
anybody here work on the books project?
So the early days of our book scanning
project was basically Larry and Sergei
arguing about how quickly
you could digitize a book
and and using a photocopier
to sort of figure out the mechanics of
doing it was very much the same kind of
problem here.
It's very, it's a very
rudimentary problem in some ways,
but I think things like
computer vision for example,
a critical to then helping stitch
some of those images together.
So we can use a rig where we can take
a number of oblique images of that
specimen, automatically
stitch it together, run OCR,
run handwriting recognition across that
and that Paul of material that then
fails those tests we then put through to
our crowd sourcing so that then humans
can start intervening
and getting that data.
The first key challenge is the large
scale digitization of those artifacts in
and species specimens and so on.
Yeah.
And what else did it,
so the next big challenge I think
is how do we exploit that data?
How do we meaningfully get data
from particularly that imagery?
So there is a, um, a huge opportunity
I think in terms of computer vision,
in terms of trying to recognize in an
automated way what those objects are and
then apply that across all sorts of
science across, across the globe.
So of course we have the authoritative
collection of all of the,
uh,
roughly 2 million species that have been
described so far and we can potentially
get imagery for sometimes 10,
sometimes hundreds of
thousands of those specimens.
So being able then to use that imagery
to facilitate things like automatic
species recognition so that
imagine someone, um, uh,
a member of the public perhaps
innocently taking a photograph out on the
Serengeti or we're basically wherever
they are and being able to automatically
recognize what's in that
image and exploit that.
That has a huge transformative potential
in terms of helping us to understand
the natural world.
What's there when it was
pick some of us were thinking
about when you were showing, uh,
when we're showing the
Lepidoptera and thinking, well,
how far away are we from just being
able to use a camera to identify how far
away are we?
Does it vary by species or,
so it really varies by tag to
something. There's some tax, uh,
some groups lend
themselves to that. So, uh,
butterflies and moths in particular
Lepidoptera because they're quite two
dimensional and many of the key
characteristics you can see in, um, uh,
in that image you can actually
get species recognition.
Certainly recognition to some of the
lower taxes for other groups, it's much,
much harder. There's much more
three dimensionality to them.
The discriminating features a tucked away,
a hidden away getting it that information
is harder, but that's the potential.
Right. And, and if we step from
what you're doing to Ian's role,
which is as director of science,
what are the things that most excite you
and that the big challenges that you're
focusing on
in this area? There's also the public
aspects of this. So we all, you know,
when you look at that museum to begin with
this, we are a scientific institution,
but we also want to get the broad public
interested in these sorts of things.
And there's a selfish reason for that
because if we think that if you want to
make politicians and so on,
bold enough to make good decisions
for the long term environment,
you need to get the
public interested in that.
And lots of events show there's
a long way to go with that.
So things like the Rumelia short source,
we were just looking at there,
that's an amazing way of literally
bringing an iconic specimen to life.
So that specimen is in the,
is one of our main halls.
It was collected right at the beginning
of this discovery period by a woman
called Mary Anning.
So great story behind it.
But by using that bit of
Vr to bring it to to life,
to give that to schools and well it
lets you tell some really interesting
stories and if you watched the video,
I showed him how to goodness knows how
many people have all sorts of ages that
totally captivated to begin with.
They liked the buzz of what they put
on the cardboard. They like that.
Then they see the Vr,
they like that.
That's still sufficiently need
to intro to interest them.
The creature comes towards them,
almost everybody kind of Ah,
you no bit scared by it.
But then afterwards,
as a narrative about the natural world
and about the oceans, that's afterwards,
that's what they want to ask you about.
So it's really,
really interesting and he couldn't
do a better thing with a specimen.
Then that series of events and the
cool thing about that, of course it's,
well we do that all the time with people
that are lucky enough to be standing,
talking to us in South Kensington.
But if you want to change society's,
mine's about things. It has to,
it has to be more than that.
And that's what that really does mean.
So you,
you are organizing the natural world's
information and making it accessible and
useful to everyone, which actually
ring true to us as well. Yeah. Um,
and do you worry about I need to get
people to the museum versus if I digitize
things they won't come or what's your
experience been of that affects the
opposite.
So the moment that you start to digitize
things and we see this for example,
with our loan, so we are in one
sense, we are a rather curious museum.
Many museums are about preserving and
holding on to things were busy sending
tens of thousands of specimens
out on academic loans every year.
And actually the experience is when you
digitize those and you make digitalized
copies of those available,
you actually get more loan requests,
more engagement, not less. So I
think quite the opposite actually.
I think digital brings many
more people physically in to uh,
engage with our collections.
One of the interesting things in music,
we see that an explosion in people going
to see music live as well as having
every recorded song in history
and they're in their pocket.
So it seems that one drives the other.
And what are the other challenges
that you face in terms of the public
engagement? I guess I don't to mention
any of the political events of this week,
but, uh, you know,
we're in a world where things may go
backwards rather than forwards in some of
these agendas.
What's the,
what's the best way for you to connect
with the policy makers and get ongoing
support?
Cause this stuff costs,
it was started by the amateurs and
that's why the by the filthy rich, but,
but now this is a real cost to it.
And how do you deal with the policy making
challenge in the funding challenge it.
So that's, um, that's a good
question about, um, the, um,
the challenge with respect to the
public and the policy makers is,
as I said when I started, this is not
to feel as though you're lecturing them.
If they come into the museum or they
come onto our different sorts of products
and they feel that they know this is going
to be a lecture about giving more aid
with respect to diseases or climate
change or habitat, um, usage and saw,
they veer away from that.
So as with lots of different
media advertising for example,
you've got to get a smart
way into their head,
get the hook into their head and
then start to talk and almost they're
interested.
Talk to them about the bigger piece.
So you can see that the sorts of objects
we were just talking about that they're
fascinating. Um, they've got some
interesting scientific points about them,
but there are way into people's heads
and that's the way we often use it in
terms of funding and so on.
What we see and the way of funding these
sorts of missions is a combination of
government support and then
getting different sorts of
entrepreneurial support.
So if you look around the world,
that institutions that have done
most digitalization typically so far,
they've usually been doing that based
on substantial government support.
I'd say the limitation of that is
that doesn't necessarily make you very
innovative. You get 10 million bucks
to do your botanical collection.
So you do that and then you stop doing it.
What we want to create is
a set of platforms that
anybody can do it anywhere and
it's much cheaper and so on to do that.
So I see that sweet spot as the
government support plus different sorts of
entrepreneurial ventures as well.
Yeah, I was just going to
him and I think one, the,
the one cap on top of that also
isn't really great science,
which demonstrates why
this data is so important.
And that slide that we
had just earlier the,
the work actually that drew was involved
in demonstrating that we have lost
significant fractions of biodiversity
and that if we continue along that path,
we will lose a, at an increasing rate.
That biodiversity is a great illustration.
Was going to ask you a bit more about that
exactly at this point actually. So, uh,
tell us more about how
you're using the data.
You have the historic data to extrapolate
the future trends and to highlight
these issues. What are the challenges
there? What's it showing it?
So that project used,
um,
a mixture of basically data
mining but very human intensive,
rather laborious,
actually data mining.
So an army has students rated lots of
scientific literature that was basically
showing changing patterns
of the biodiversity before
and after land use change.
And by knowing what was there and by
knowing what was there now and being able
to classify those different habitats,
we can start to then see where there's
been the most biodiversity loss.
And we can also start to
model how a future things
like climate change scenarios
for example,
are going to impact that loss.
Because the good news and there
is some good news from this,
is that some of those climate change
scenarios can mitigate that rate of loss
and we can actually start to repair some
of the damage that we've been doing.
So tell us a bit more about what's shown
here and about the work that you're
doing it with a machine learning expert.
Do you want to talk about it all in
on it? So this is a, um, this is, uh,
this is just the trust real
world at the moment. Uh,
but this is showing the
percentage of original um,
flora and fauna that are
still there. So, um, if you,
um, I think that's the way around if it
is yes. So if you've got a blue number,
that means that a large proportion
of bloop color that's um,
a large proportion of the species are
still intact. Um, as it gets redder,
it means that an increasingly large
proportion of being lost and there's all
sorts of different ways you
can add those numbers up.
Obviously the main conclusions to this,
a pretty robust to those sorts
of differences in exactly
which species you glue.
Now what you can see is the global average
is that we've lost about 13% or so of
species.
What you can also see is that it's
incredibly heterogeneously distributed.
There are some areas,
often whether it's relatively low
species that are relatively intact,
there are also places such as the Amazon
basin there that you can see that are
intact. You can see there are some other
areas that are an incredibly disturbed.
Now at the moment, one of the
interesting things, stroke,
terrifying things is we don't actually
know what the function looks like between
this type of species count
and ecological functioning.
Now these guys have also been doing
some work on another index called, um,
whether trying to actually estimate the
effects of this on ecosystems that's an
unexplored, well, it's very exciting,
but a relatively unexplored area.
So we don't know whether there are people
called tipping points in this system
or whatever.
There are linear relationships and so on.
One of the other cool things about
natural history collections is they are
literally a time machine.
So they're one of the,
one of very few on and ambiguous ways
that you can go back a few hundred years.
And Matt,
what's been happening and those few
hundred years that we've been around
collecting things or our ancestors
had been around collecting things,
of course was exactly the moment when
Western civilization started going around
the world and driving a lot of this.
So it's a,
I suppose it's a fortunate accident.
At the same time we started exploiting
the world and doing this to it.
We were collecting through that period.
So it's a time machine. The, the, um,
the challenge now is to open that up now
we've done some of that analytically so
we can push some of these graphs back
to about 1500 using some generalizations
about the way the world works with
respect to the sort of habitats that are
there.
But these collections offered
the opportunity to be much
more specific than that
as well.
Well, um, can,
can you say a little bit about how you've
collaborated with the deep mind team
or with, with the Google
teams. What's that been like?
How easy was it to just, Oh,
it was obvious we need to do this and how
much was it trying to figure out a way
of working?
So come on, be honest. We ask now. Well,
it's, it's, there are good things to say,
so it's easy to be honest. When we first
started talking to each other, um, yes,
there's that classic cultural
difference about, you know,
what's important and so on.
I found that,
well I found that a mixture of incredibly
rewarding and very, very challenging.
So sometimes I'll talk to
a couple of your guys, um,
and they will start to ask me,
so why do you,
why do you bring botanical
specimens back to the museum?
So doing it for 200 years, young
man, that's the way we do it.
But once you go through the whole
flow of why you're doing it,
the information that you can see,
we could capture all of that in the field.
Now you realize the only
reason to actually bring the
specimen back is just as a
voucher for all of that information.
So sometimes it completely changes
how you think. And to be honest,
for an institution that's 200 years old,
that's one of the big things
you've got to be doing.
You've got to be challenging
yourself on very fun. You know,
why collect and if you're
going to collect tomorrow,
why the hell are you going to collect
the same way as he did 200 years ago?
You should throw that out
and completely rethink it.
The second layer for you is,
yeah,
you guys work quickly in a very,
very nimble way.
So we like to plan projects going on,
plenty of paperwork there,
maybe plan it again and that
sort of thing. And you know,
we'll do that over a couple of years.
Um, where you guys are kind of say,
so I remember when we were doing the
Romaleos saurus there, let's do it.
Let's do a Vr of this. Oh, okay.
That's that kind of us, you know,
that's a good idea. This is
what it would involve. Caitlin.
And we were thinking six months a year,
let's do it by the end of the week.
Now for us, that's an
unbelievably challenging
timescale, but it's been a good,
isn't it? Yeah, absolutely. I mean,
I think that agility was what I was
going to pick up on. I think, again,
really in science,
particularly digital science,
we used to having to work quite quickly.
So in one sense that
wasn't such a problem.
But working with some of the other bits
of the museum which are may be not quite
so comfortable with that. Um, uh, that,
that degree of speed of working.
I remember with the tank room,
it was quite literally the decision was
made the night before to do the filming.
So being able to turn the museum around
to secure the permissions necessary to
do that filming and literally to
be in there the following morning,
that is quite a challenge.
We showed it to her,
this amazing room that you go into, which
has got historical samples all around.
Absolutely wonderful. The wonderful
curator that knows every specimen.
There's the original sealer camp and
things in there. We show this to say,
I think I was about five
o'clock by the time we got all,
he was telling us stories and we said,
why don't we put this on the
cultural institutes? So what he says,
if you've got an objection, no objection,
but how are we going to do that?
Because if I can get the right team here,
I guess eight o'clock the next morning,
can we film
this and do the videos and
do the three d modeling.
So if you can get your team here by
eight o'clock we'll be here. Yeah.
And we did it the next morning and now
we've been trying to do that center since
I've been at the museum.
So to be able to accelerate
things at that pace of the half,
that attitude and those resources to be
able to really have that team the next
morning knocking on the door. And
they were incredible. And I was,
I was actually just watching that.
It's a three 60 video. And is it,
is it only the,
the,
the curator of all things fish and
it's brilliant because it's extremely
accessible. He's a natural. He's, he
should be on television and now he,
and now he is. So that's part
of making it accessible and uh,
any difficulties, I mean there's
obviously there's a pace thing,
there's a bit of an agility thing.
You mentioned any difficulties where
we were just at cross purposes or,
or the agenda that our teams had was,
was just at odds with what was
going to drive your work forward?
I don't think they are, I don't think
there are major differences like that.
I think it, that challenge
eventually is prioritization.
So whenever we're in a room together,
we can come up with 20 cool ideas and
then it's the case that was 20 it was a
short meeting and then it's
a case of figuring out, okay,
which ones are we going to work on?
Work on next. Really. So that's what,
this is an exciting challenge.
So I want to come to the audience and
that get any questions or suggestions or
thoughts you have.
So just raise your hand and it has a
mic if you want to do any of that while
you're having a think about
really smart questions. Uh,
just kind of coming back to you and
the work that you're doing, what,
what do you see as being the
biggest areas of potential next?
You've talked a bit about the
kind of near term challenges,
but where do you think this could
go? So I mean I think, I think
ultimately the really grand challenge
is not what we've talked about here is
obviously relevant to the
natural history museum,
but there are literally hundreds,
thousands of natural history museums all
around the globe that have entirely the
same problem.
Ian Talk Right at the beginning about
that figure of roughly 1.5 to 3 billion
specimens in natural history collections.
So how do we take our problem that we
have at the natural history museum and
build solutions that work for all of
those institutions to try and extract that
data? Because for me, the really
grand vision, if you like,
as to what we're going to do with all
of that data is to try to model the
natural world.
So by that I mean take literally every
facet of information that we've possibly
got. Everything about the
taxonomy, the evolutionary history,
the traits of the phenotypic traits,
the morphological traits of the specimen,
the genotypic information,
all of the a biotic information as well,
and start to model that.
So that we have a very
precise understanding of
what the natural world is,
what's happening to it and how can we
mitigate the rest about that to the
natural world.
That is probably the ultimate and most
inclusive grand challenge because it
basically encompasses or the scientists
involved in the study of the natural
world, all the institutions,
all the collections,
and also the tremendous body of literature
that we've already generated on this.
In a curious way,
our science is a little bit unusual to a
number of other science sciences in the
loss of the documentation
about the natural world,
even if it was written 300 years
ago is still highly relevant today.
And then you can't say that
about physics or astronomy,
but you can say that about our science.
So we have 300 million pages of text,
pretty much that have been,
that represent the corpus of knowledge
that had been written so far about the
natural world.
We have a big program to digitize that.
We've done about 50 million
of those pages so far. Um,
but trying to then extract meaning,
semantic meaning from that
is also a huge opportunity.
But that grand vision is to really bring
it all together in an integrative way
so that we have effectively at all for
the whole of the scientific communities.
That's striking when you talk,
I mean I think we see this in many areas
that were in different disciplines come
together. That's when creativity
in innovation really happens.
You talk in a way that I'm
not see biologists talk
about platforms and data and
applying that to problems or others in
your field starting to do the same thing.
Or are you a as the British navy world?
I think? Well I think the beginning too,
but the challenge also is
partly there one of resources.
So it's relatively easy for someone to
innovate digitally and to do something in
a very sort of project oriented way.
It usually takes,
depending upon the nature of that,
the initiative may be five or 10 times
the amount of revolt resource to actually
build a robust platform that will
then work and scale in a sensible way.
So I think in terms of leadership,
yes we probably are leading
the way in some of those, um,
development of some of those platforms.
But I think it's partly also we're
often trying to serve many different
audiences.
We have to build projects.
Often it's more project
oriented than program or um,
platform oriented and trying to bridge
that gap between if you like the project
and the program.
That's the hard bit,
that scaling bit something that
Google of course have done so well.
I'm just thinking of if be talking to
another when my colleagues questions,
thoughts, suggestions
for the guests. Yeah.
Yeah. So you were talking about
the loss of biodiversity. Um,
I assume there are people who say,
why should I care that there are only 84
flies where they used to be 100 flies.
Um,
so what did you reply to those people?
That's very hard one to answer
actually. I remember, uh,
I remember that same query being made on
a radio four program to a very eminent
scientist actually a few years ago.
And he actually,
well he was rather colorful
in his language in terms
of how he replied because
the truthful answer is
we often don't know.
You could imagine each of these species
as being like a book full of pages that
we've yet to read. Now we don't
know what the value is necessarily
in preserving or keeping
all of those species.
We can talk in a cultural and a
social sense about general, um,
value of biodiversity.
But the specifics of that particular
fly is very hard to pin down.
All I can say is if you imagine each
of those species was like a library,
you would not burn the library
just because you hadn't read it.
You'd probably at least read it first.
That's one ounce.
I don't know whether you've got a
better one. No, that's um, well the,
the other answer we use is
we often go into, uh, if,
if it's somebody who wants an answer from
a very human perspective than what we
often use is the concept
of ecosystem services.
So we know that at some stage
if you carry on doing this,
eventually you are going to screw up
to an enormous degree because almost
everything, if you ask, you know what you
ate this morning, what you're dressed in,
everybody here, I would imagine this,
you haven't had anything to eat yet.
Well I've had some plants to eat this um,
this morning beat through bread or through
cereals or temperament that might be
you'll be dressed in things
that come from plants and so on.
Now at the moment those systems, um, we
can, we can still harvest those systems.
The water that you get will have come
through some sort of natural system is
what almost all the resources
that you ultimately rely on,
including the resources that
are in technical devices.
And so they're coming from natural
systems and now at the moment we are,
we are just staring that bucket.
If you're,
I could a fairly vigorous rate and so
far we can see things going wrong but we
can still harvest it. We don't yet
know how long we can keep doing that.
We can use this map of
course to demonstrate between
different sites sites was
good.
Intactness and science with
pouring tactless with respect
to species demonstrate
ecosystem services really
start to deteriorate.
And so that's the kind of more
strategic and sort of feel like that if
everything that we depend on is ultimately
a natural system on this planet,
um, and we need to, we need to
keep that intact for humanity.
And there are thumb systems that are
exceedingly vulnerable at the moment.
The coral reefs would be
a great example of that.
We're about to hit a tipping point due to,
um,
a rising sea temperature
in ocean acidification,
which probably means that by about 20,
50,
virtually every single coral reef will
have very significant damage and some
will just simply be wiped out because
their tolerance to that environmental
change is just simply too narrow.
They can't cope.
So many of those or all the services
that are dependent from tourism,
from fishing, from the ornamental
fish trade, uh, through, uh,
to, um, uh, yeah, there's a,
a world of economic loss that will also
happen when we lose those coral reefs.
I guess this kind of modeling will
allow us to understand things like if we
don't honor the Paris climate
agreement for example,
what kind of implications there could be.
You extrapolate exactly.
One of the really interesting when you
asked before matter about effectively how
to influence policy makers.
I don't know why it's on my mind.
I'm sorry I'm putting aside some um,
challenging examples.
Another error.
I think that we need to get smarter in
this as well as getting a kind of the
suitable hook into their mind.
We also need to give them solutions as
well as problems and some of the work
that comes out of this project has really
interesting in that respect and that
you've probably all familiar with the,
with the hawks called the hockey
stick curves for climate change.
So it goes them from relatively cool in
the path and it goes up at an alarming
rate with why it's called the hockey stick
curve and at the right hand side that
it's got different scenarios. It's usually
got four to six different scenarios.
As a biologist, I look at that with
real MB because that little guy,
you're really modeling
the physical world there.
You know you've got a bit of climate
that you got a bit of historical climate
data in thirds and climate data and so on.
Now what the team behind this that is
that taking that challenges that we should
be able to model the biological world
in the same way we should know what's
happened in the past.
We should be able to calculate what's
happening now and most importantly predict
what's happening in the future based on
exactly the same scenarios that they're
using for climate change and so on,
which are usually based on things
like how many people there are,
what you're doing with respect to
reforestation and carbon storage and what
you're doing with respect
to burning fossil fuels and
songs and that's what that
team have done so you can now show
us similar biodiversity curve,
which from 1500 it goes along.
It comes down in a really alarming fashion
as we spread our agricultural around
the world,
which also drives this pattern here.
Then the different curves at the end
there that predict what would happen under
different future worlds.
They are really different.
Some of them just continue to go down.
So you're heading,
I would say you're heading there
towards an ecosystem crisis.
You're going to get major
services collapsing,
but even under some of the models that
are being that are being used now,
some of them are curving up within 50
years and one of the main drivers for that
is about how we reforest and how
we look after carbon and so on.
So there you can say to policymakers
instead of saying it's all a disaster,
you're going to have to
spend a lot of money,
but it's probably not during your term,
not very attractive.
You can say you guys can save the world.
Look at this.
If you reforest it in this way and
drove your fuel policies in this way,
within 50 years people
are going to be having a,
people are going to be feeling
the difference on a global scale.
We haven't really been able to do that
before because suddenly it becomes a
doable challenge and 50 years,
okay.
It's outside the normal elections
and election cycle. Sure. Um,
but I think 50 years is the sort of time
period that people realize that that's
either me or my kids.
It's certainly my grandkids.
So it's a tangible period that you
can make a difference and it's, um,
and it's very visually
compelling when you do that.
So I think that's one of
our challenges to present.
So to find solutions and present them in
a way that policy makers can work with
them. Wow. Great. And
we've got there from flies.
Other questions? Here we go. Um,
so on that graph,
how come?
Europe doesn't seem to be as devastated
as like Australia or America.
Okay. So, um, can you guess
why Australia is bright red,
particularly the central
of Australia there.
Okay.
Ozone Layer. Sorry. Um, so, so why
was that and why climate change?
One of the affects of sheep,
sheep and rabbits have had an enormous
effect on the species that would live in
Australia. So a few introduced
species buyers had devastated the bio,
the bio terrain of the
middle of Australia. Um,
so sometimes you get massive
effects like that. Um,
you can see often it's
associated with that. The best,
the best way usually of
destroying biodiversity is
to suddenly to have an area
that's quite bad by diverse,
rich and suddenly tried to increase
the gross domestic product of that area
because then you basically just have to
take every resource out of that. Well,
places like Europe, we're not an
enormously diverse area. We are,
we have relatively protected
landscapes compared to some,
so we still have some of our
biodiversity and left. Um,
if you look across North America,
you can see where that big
belt is through the middleware.
Anybody had the pleasure of driving
across the central of America.
You can see what's kind of been going on
there. There's mass industrial size, um,
agriculture, very difficult
for by domestic to cope with.
And it's thinks like the
advances in artificial nitrogen
fixing and productivity.
You,
you alluded to that there,
but it just tell us it has a bit more
about how those kinds of practices have
affected this as far as you understand.
Okay. So I mean, what's going to
affect this in the future? Um,
a lot of this is to do with, um,
it's a couple of big effects.
It's how many people you have around,
um,
how will you control the climate
and how you manage those habitats.
They're clearly that, you know,
from an environmental perspective,
the ideal thing is to have a
relatively low number of people, um,
to control the environment and then to
manage those habitats in a way that is
relatively sustainable and it's achieving
the balance across those things.
I mean,
I don't think any of us are saying we
don't want to harvest new materials.
If you look through, for example,
South America, there you can,
one of the challenges with the
changes in Colombia, for example,
absolutely amazing
biodiversity in Colombia.
One of the reasons it probably exists
in some areas is it would be far too
dangerous to go in there. You know, I've
discussed with them in the past thing.
How about we explore
there and how about we,
it's going to say you do not want to go
through that valley with your binoculars
and you'll, you know little, you're
welcome. Yeah. So in those sorts of,
there's also amazing minerals in Colombia
which will power the technologies that
a lot of us are dependent upon.
That's where the new batteries and then
new screens and so on are going to come
from and those sorts of things.
And our challenge is to try to be
able to extract those minerals in a
sustainable way but keep the bone
adversity as intact as possible.
That's really challenging,
but it's very conspicuous that already,
since those deals are starting
to happen in Colombia,
they are over here talking to
us about exactly how to do that.
So you're talking about major areas
of South America where you can make a
difference about how biodiversity is
going to go there in the next 10 years or
so. Really excited, but they
need data to, it's good.
It's going to be a data driven solution
that thereafter. Other questions?
Hi, it's my wife is a zoological
research fellow and uh,
at the various universities she's gone
to the state of the art for recording
data tends to be an excel
spreadsheet at the top end. Um,
reducing down to,
she does bird rain,
bird ringing and bartering is often just
recorded on scraps of paper which are
mailed it to each other.
Um,
what can we do and what can
you do to help improve the, uh,
the recording and the sharing of high
quality data from the academic community?
So I think,
I mean I'll try and answer that one.
I think fundamentally it's platforms
is building platforms that support the
acquisition of that data.
The fact that it needs to be done
offline because many of the places where
people are doing that recording,
they don't have digital connectivity.
The synchronization and integration of
that data is a big challenge. Um, so yeah,
I,
I feel your pain to some degree because
I've been involved in that community for
quite some time.
Um,
often there are communities of practice
that are quite as difficult to change.
There's a cultural problem there as well
in terms of trying to shift people away
from bits of paper to recording
things natively. Uh, digitally.
There's also issues about
devices when you bring devices,
particularly into some parts of the field,
you know that they're going
to get wet is extremely hot.
It's humid a or sometimes
it's freezing cold. Um,
the issue about connectivity is there's
also critical is we've had to in some
cases build really big
temporary wifi networks.
We do some work in Lyme,
Regis and just on the beach.
There is no good connectivity.
So you need to put in basic infrastructure
like a wifi network just to be able
to get citizens to help recording and
documenting, um, uh, what's on the beach.
So I think Google, uh,
organizations like ourselves,
other natural history based
organizations in the UK, uh,
have a key role in trying to, um, uh,
build those systems,
those platforms to try and deliver
that transition toward digital.
But it's, it's a, it's a challenge
partly because it's a cultural thing.
It's not really a technology thing.
Another question here, I
think. Yeah, thanks. Um,
so we were talking about environmental
policy before and I guess one of the
biggest challenges is that it only really
works is if all the countries around
the word work together and
pull in the same direction.
And I guess is this something
you're trying do by making
your collection available online or
how can we use that to convince people
around the word? So, uh,
there is a very strong link between
all those natural history collections
worldwide. It tends to start, it tends
to be kind of at the continental level,
predominantly the conversations.
So for example,
I sit on an organization
called [inaudible],
the consortium of European
taxonomic facilities,
which represents the 50 major natural
history collections across about 20
countries in Europe.
And we talk constantly about basically
how we can share technologies.
We can develop a common
agenda, uh, to, um, uh, to, to,
to basically provide the data,
the platforms or systems to make
this kind of science possible.
So I would say at that level
there's very good communication.
I think where the is
perhaps slightly less,
but obviously us being here today is a
good example of where we're trying to
bridge that is with the commercial sector
and with technology organizations who
can really have a pivotal role in helping
us to make that leap towards making
this content more accessible,
more digital and support the underlying.
It provides some of the
underlying infrastructure,
which is quite hard for us
to provide individually.
But through organizations like Google,
there is a potential to um, to provide,
let me get,
let's give you that opportunity then.
What would be the questions you'd ask of
us as a partner in some of that journey?
Where can you see that we have
the most potential to be held?
Cool.
So I mean I think there's a number of
them are probably the three big ones are
digitization,
just simply trying to exploit some of
the digitization technologies that you've
got. Obviously you have enormous
experience with the book digitization.
This is quite a different proposition in
one sense, but there are many parallels.
So that's one. I think the foundational
platforms, the hosting, the storage,
the cloud infrastructure,
that's a big challenge for us
because it's truly global. But again,
it's an area where Google can help.
And I think the other big one is helping
us to demonstrate the potential of a
lot of this digital content. And that's
where I think the machine learning,
the computer vision,
the um,
technologies that can help us to exploit
and extract data from all of this
imagery that we're data generating.
That's the third big area. I think
that's it. It sounds like that
third area splits into sort of the,
the intelligent extrapolations and so
on that can engage in the policy and
public fund as well as the captivating
animations that that bring in.
Absolutely.
So we can engage
snapchat,
accomplish and do the science and really
tell the public about that science
and see, hey, is here from the Cultural
Institute team you want to get,
just give a wave. So if people
want to sort of say, Hey,
I'd love to help follow up on this,
then that's the place to,
that's the place to talk.
Any final questions from anybody?
We're about to be out of time.
Yeah.
Okay. So I have a, I have a
final question. Uh, you know, it,
given where you are in your field and
the progress that you're seeing made,
what would you predict it in sort
of 10 years is going to have been a
breakthrough, uh, that's,
that could be achieved in,
in any of the fields that
you're working in. Where,
where do you see that there's some,
some potential for something
significant to change?
I think definitely for me it's the
potential force and species or times on
recognition and images.
I think that's going to
be truly transformative to
the kind of science that we
can do because it empowers people who
are frankly not necessarily very informed
about the natural world to suddenly
be able to record and document it.
If we can automatically do things like
identify species from that imagery that
has a revolutionizes fieldwork,
for example,
imagine the fact that we have to send
physically lots of people out to these
sometimes very dangerous
places to do that work.
We can basically put devices into those
places and do that recording in an
automated way.
We can do things like identify when
new things that we didn't know about.
I've come into a region when things that,
um,
maybe some of those are new species,
maybe some of those things are um, uh, uh,
things that we simply didn't know were
there that is going to have a huge
transformative impact I think on
how we understand the natural world.
Well so that the entire planet becomes
your collection. Exactly. Yeah.
Do you have a similar view?
Um, I'll have to be a bit
different from Vince. I agree
with that. That's, you know,
the new expedition, the
new global expedition using
new technologies and stuff.
The one thing I would add to what we've
spoken about so far is everything we've
just spoken about now you also
link that to genomic information.
So we also want to understand how
life evolves and how it works. Now,
I would say that you guys would
probably know more about this than me,
but if you think about, um, where we
are in terms of digital technology, um,
genomes have been going along
a similar trajectory. The old,
the old approach was kind of let's try
and get one genome for one species.
We've done it. Now we've got um,
genomes for maybe a hundred species,
jolly good. Now we're starting
to do a little bit of population.
So a thousand or 10,000 humans get a bit
of variety in there. Really exciting is,
but in the same way as technology has got
faster and better in the digital realm
and cheaper exactly the same as
happened in the genomic realm as well.
So now we're into biodiversity genomics.
So you look at the forms of all the
different animals and plants around you.
We want to understand how that happened
and what it means for their evolution
and again,
for their responses to future change.
So there's a big database over
there that's growing really rapidly,
all about genomes. This is where a
lot of the information is actually,
the biological information is thought.
We've got to link those two together,
and I think there's going to
be a lot of fun doing that.
Well, I want to say thank you for
enduring my simplistic questions,
but there's a real sense here of a field
that is ready for a big acceleration at
a time,
which we probably need it more than ever.
So I want to say a big
thank you to doctor.
Ian owns doctor Vince Smith for all their
time and for our partnership with the
Natural History Museum.
Thank you very much.